bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
l'une des figures les plus connues de la
chronique judiciaire bonsoir Dominique
verdaillan bonsoir 30 ans à arpenter les
cours d'assises et les prétoirs pour
nous faire les grands procès et votre
livre les magistrats de divan vient de
reparaître il prend un relief
particulier on va en parler alors on est
juges sont encore et toujours sur la
sellette on a du temps en étant sans
pendant une heure pour décrypter
l'actualité de ce premier février au
sommaire ce soir retraite la parole aux
députés au lendemain de la mobilisation
la bataille va se jouer désormais à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que peut-on
attendre du débat parlementaire va-t-on
tout droit vers le pugilat sur quoi le
texte peut-il encore bouger grand
décryptage avec nos invités dans un
instant avant de retrouver nos parties
pris nos affranchis aux alentours de
20h15 et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée vous me
suivez Dominique verdaillon ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
et maintenant place à l'Assemblée il y
avait une grosse magnétière et pourtant
et bien elle se joue aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale cette bataille depuis le début
de la semaine en commission et puis
surtout garder bien cette date en tête
lundi le 6 février ça commencera dans
l'hémicycle le tout va durer jusqu'au 17
février c'est compliqué il y a une
procédure parlementaire on a besoin de
comprendre et d'être le plus clair
possible grâce à nos quatre experts ce
soir bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être là
éditorialiste à BFM TV et conseiller
éditorial de franc tireur bonsoir
anne-charlen Bedina bonsoir Myriam ravi
de vous retrouver vous êtes
constitutionnaliste et maître de
conférence en droit public j'aurais mis
Baudot bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes un
peu chez vous ici vous êtes chroniqueur
dans cette émission mais aussi à France
Info le brief politique 7h24 tous les
matins et bien sûr merci de
m'accompagner Elsa mon dingava Elsa qui
suit de près ce feuilleton parlementaire
sur les retraites sur sur LCP bien sûr
alors Dominique verdaillon vous êtes un
très grand vulgarisateur et c'est un
compliment dans ma bouche donc si vous
comprenez pas sentez-vous libre
absolument d'intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez on va commencer par planter le
décor comme chaque soir on a choisi
d'abord de commencer par la stratégie du
gouvernement on a l'impression qu'il y a
un peu plus de fébrilité c'est ces
derniers jours le chrono de Blacko pour
nous présenter tout cela Stéphane
blackovski mesdames messieurs pour
commencer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir
Stéphane
du haut de votre estrade alors bonsoir à
toutes bonsoir à tous bonsoir Stéphane
dans quel état d'esprit et l'exécutif à
l'aube de cette bataille dans
l'hémicycle alors je les connais pas
tous même pas du tout mais à mon avis
ils ont quand même petit prix un petit
coup au moral hier vis-à-vis de la
mobilisation surtout que c'est pas fini
il y avait de plus en plus de monde hier
mais encore deux manifs de prévu dont
une le samedi donc la foule risque
encore de grimper bon enfin en même
temps soyons positif faut pas toujours
voir le verre à moitié vide et il y
avait une bonne nouvelle hier c'est que
Laurent Berger a tendu la main au
gouvernement il lui a dit mais si bien
sûr à Elisabeth borde on peut négocier
c'est pas si compliqué on l'écoute si
Madame borde dit ce soir on revient sur
l'âge légal à 64 ans et on le remet à 62
ans on va aller discuter ouais il y a
mais ça c'est l'histoire d'amour
impossible parce que ce que réclame le
renverger c'est justement parce que
Elisabeth borne refuse de lui alors
comment ça a démarré elle était
tranquillement dans cette
circonscription à Vire dans le Calvados
ce week-end France Info lui a attendu un
micro et elle a dit les 64 ans c'est pas
négociable mais qu'est-ce qu'elle avait
pas dit immédiatement comme une traînée
de poudre TF1 repris RTL s'en empare le
Parisien c'était la une bombe bref le
samedi soir on avait tous compris que
Élisabeth borne refuse de négocier et
donc on se disait bah aller comme Juppé
droite dans ses bottes et ça c'est
jamais vraiment bon signe et droit de
lancer bottes comme Juppé pour une
réforme des retraites vous voyez ce que
je veux dire bref ce matin Olivier du
soft lui était de retour sur France 2 et
donc il avait bien en tête à
mobilisation d'hier et donc pas question
de dire que les 64 ans n'étaient pas
négociables mais il était face à Thomas
Soto quel genre de journaliste qui quand
il vous demande est-ce que la réforme
est négociable et que vous lui répondez
pas il vous repose la question regarde
là je l'égale de départ à 64 ans est-ce
que ça reste non négociable cet âge
reste non négociable au lendemain des
manifestations là moi je veux savoir la
réponse à la rue d'hier est-ce que l'âge
de 64 ans reste négociable 1 2 3 il a
posé trois fois la question c'est quand
même pas compliqué c'est négociable ou
pas négociable c'est oui ou c'est non
non ça justement c'est ça qui a été très
très fort bravo Olivier du socle il a
pas dit que c'était pas négociable il a
pas dit que c'était négociable donc lui
vraiment très très fort en même temps
Thomas Soto a fini par reposer une
quatrième fois la question en écoute
est-ce que là
je viens de vous répondre que si nous ne
faisons pas 64 ans mon équilibrons pas
le système il a pas dit oui il a pas dit
formidable bon en même temps faut
reconnaître que la difficulté du
gouvernement en ce moment c'est que ils
ont fait beaucoup de concessions avant
justement qu'on en arrive aux
manifestations des concessions qui ont
été faites pendant des concertations
avec les syndicats du coup maintenant il
y a plus grand chose à négocier et le
problème c'est que personne ne se
souvient que beaucoup de concessions ont
déjà été faites enfin si il y en a un
qui s'en souvient c'est Gabriel Attal
parce qu'il est jeune il est de la
mémoire alors il se souvient bien en
écoute
il y a eu des mois de concertation avec
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
avec mon collègue Olivier dussote on
était au départ à 65 ans on est passé à
64 ans au départ la revalorisation des
petites retraites c'était que pour les
nouveaux retraités maintenant ça sera
aussi pour les retraités actuels on a
élargi la prise en compte de la
pénibilité ah oui mais quand on a plus
rien négocier c'est vrai qu'on est un
petit peu embarrassé face aux syndicats
alors que faire ils sont un peu acrant
peut-être vous avez remarqué que
peut-être Isabelle borne c'était un peu
monté d'un cran en tout cas dans son
expression cet après-midi au Sénat
c'était Olivier du soft qui hier c'était
aussi lui aussi un peu énervé à
l'Assemblée donc là fini la pédagogie il
est carrément passé aux menaces on
l'écoute
si nous retirions cette réforme
le système serait déficitaire il
s'écroulerait et la pension le niveau
moyen de revenus au niveau de moyens des
pensions des retraités baisserait de 20%
comme c'est indiqué dans le conseil
d'orientation du corps
les pensions baisseraient de 20% alors
ça vraiment c'est vraiment un truc dans
tenir compte donc on se dit mais alors
dans le rapport du corps bien sûr je me
suis plongé mon petit journaliste en
rapport c'est quoi une pension moyenne
donc voilà comment ça se calcule c'est
dans le rapport du corps donc c'est
quand même un truc un peu compliqué les
retraites on en parle comme ça mais
c'est parfois plus compliqué que ce
qu'on pense en fait Elsa heureusement
était là elle a appelé le cabinet qui
lui dit de quoi il parlait donc il
parlait de la figure de a de 5A vous
allez voir qui est effectivement montre
des courbes qui ont l'air de plonger de
20% vous voyez là on serait en 2022 là
on serait là on se dit ouais il y a une
chute mais en fait ça ne dit pas que il
va y avoir un appauvrissement des
retraités dans le futur c'est même
précisé précisément dans le rapport ça
dit juste que le les revenus des
retraités vont augmenter moins vite que
ceux des et donc l'écart entre le revenu
des actifs et là les revenus des
retraités va sans doute baisser de 20%
rigoureux jusque là dans chacune de ces
interventions commence à dire des trucs
qui sont pas tout à fait vrai pas tout à
fait faux on se demande si le
gouvernement est pas en train de perdre
ses nerfs
pour votre débat merci beaucoup Stéphane
bajustement Christophe Barbier on a
l'impression vraiment que la stratégie
de communication a changé on parle au
départ il y a quelques jours quoi à peu
près deux semaines d'une réforme juste
et puis aujourd'hui on est vraiment sur
et bah c'est une réforme d'effort et
puis elle est impopulaire et on l'assume
comment vous expliquer ce changement de
pied c'est parce que la première méthode
de communication a échoué elle a échoué
sur tous les plans montrer que c'était
nécessaire c'est à moitié passé on voit
bien que les pays européens voisins
l'ont fait on voit bien les histoires de
déficit il y a ce rapport incroyable
avec cette équation complètement folle
je sais pas si elle est vraie vous avez
vu en exposant un endroit c'est marqué
décédé c'est peut-être les morts et on
compte on va demander au corps enfin
bref la nécessité c'est pas complètement
passée dans l'opinion l'urgence c'est
pas passé du tout on nous dit mais
attendez les déficits c'est à partir de
2027 2030 c'est horizon 2070 donc
pourquoi la faire maintenant alors qu'on
sort de la covid qu'on est dans une
crise de l'inflation vous pouvez pas
attendre deux trois ans trois quatre ans
et puis elle était censée être juste
cette réforme et cet argument là il
n'est pas passé du tout il s'est même
retourné contre le gouvernement
peut-être juste au niveau macro social
oui supprimer les régimes spéciaux les
petites retraites à 1200 euros ça donne
l'impression que globalement ça va être
plus juste après qu'avant mais quand on
regarde individuellement on trouve une
femme qui a eu tendance et qui veillent
perdre on trouve quelqu'un qui a
commencé à travailler à moins de 20 ans
et qui va y perdre chacun regarde son
cas il se dit bah finalement je vais
travailler un an deux ans de plus et
qu'est-ce que j'y gagnerai en retrait de
supplémentaire donc cet argument de la
justice si c'est effondré donc on en
revient à une autre communication qui à
mon avis aurait dû être la première et
qui collait mieux je crois la
personnalité d'Elizabeth borne c'est une
réforme difficile ça va vous demander
des efforts
c'est dur mais c'est nécessaire pour le
pays pour vos enfants pour vos
petits-enfants un peu de churchilla
voyait sans excès mais montrer que cette
réforme eh ben c'est une réforme fondée
sur l'effort de tous la somme des
efforts de chacun donc ça peut pas être
une bonne nouvelle mais c'est nécessaire
Jérémy Baudot ça le gouvernement la
compris en coulisse on reconnaît une
forme d'échec de la communication échec
sur plusieurs points la question des
femmes Christophe en parlait à l'instant
de savoir est-ce que notamment quand on
s'est rendu compte avec le rapport
d'impact que l'étude d'impact que
finalement les femmes qui avaient donc
les maires de famille qui avait des
trimestres qui leur permettaient de
compenser en partie des périodes
d'inactivité et bien que cette trimestre
en fait ne compensez pas n'était plus
compensées en fait par cette par le
report de l'âge légal la question la
durée de cotisation aussi tout cet
imbroglio et revenir les carrières
longues des carrières longues et puis
des de ceux qui ont commencé à 20 21 ans
22 ans et qui en fait sont une grosse
partie de la population moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que quand vous parlez avec
Olivier du soft si vous ces derniers
mois il disait c'est une réforme je l'ai
vraiment en tête on l'a travaillé depuis
des mois des mois des mois j'ai presque
toutes les couleurs possibles de la de
la réforme il y a plus qu'à appuyer sur
le bouton tout est prêt on se rend
compte qu'en fait c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça et que en fait il y a
des tas de choses qu'il n'avaient soit
pas anticipé soit pas voulu vraiment
voir et qui se prennent un peu l'opinion
et l'opposition de face et ça pour eux
c'est extrêmement compliqué le risque
physiquement et le risque qu'ils ont
c'est de lâcher du lest et que
finalement on le voit avec vous savez
cette retraite cette réforme elle est
censée économiser 18 milliards par an et
on se rend compte que plus ils vont
lâcher du lest plus cette réforme va
devenir
inefficace parce que on va annuler
quasiment tous les efforts demandés aux
Français en redonnant des aides ici on
va venir dans le détail sur quoi ça peut
bouger et combien ça coûte Elsa pour
bien comprendre l'état d'esprit de la
majorité aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a
des tensions est-ce que on a besoin de
resserrer les rangs et comment on prend
ce revirement au niveau des députés
Renaissance notamment il y a des
tensions alors on en a vu énormément qui
ont fait part doucement de leur
interrogation sur la réforme certains
qui allaient jusqu'à dire qu'il
voteraient contre cette réforme qui est
quand même un crime de lèse majesté
c'est un texte budgétaire normalement ça
donne l'appartenance au nom dans la
majorité et la réforme des retraites
c'est en tout cas l'alpha et l'oméga du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron certains
si vous votez pas et vous êtes
Renaissance vous êtes exprimédiatement
c'est ça la ligne aujourd'hui même
certains l'ont dit je quitterai le
groupe de moi-même reconnaissant que
c'était quand même une ligne rouge en
revanche il y en a beaucoup ceci on les
entend moi mais qui disent comme ce que
disent j'en ai mis mais maintenant il
faut y aller en fait on ne peut plus
reculer c'est une question de
crédibilité et on perdrait trop à
reculer donc en fait le groupe il est
assez divisé il y a aussi des divisions
entre Renaissance horizons le modem
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas la 72 heures de
la c'est pas des frondeurs comme à
l'époque du Parti socialiste
souder prête à resserrer les rangs
prêtes à la bataille en vrai qu'on les
sent quand même plutôt fébrile alors
anne-charlaine Medina il faut bien
comprendre dans quel cadre va avoir lieu
ce débat à l'Assemblée nationale déjà
c'est un budget
[Musique]
budget de la Sécurité sociale au projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ça change beaucoup de choses
bien sûr alors ce véhicule législatif là
il est inédit pour une réforme des
retraites toutes nos réformes des
retraites auparavant sont passées par
une loi dite ordinaire de notre article
34 de la Constitution aujourd'hui
l'argument qui est donné par la majorité
c'est de dire que et c'est vrai le la
modification de l'équilibre des
retraites est une modification de
l'équilibre du budget de la Sécurité
sociale et que comme des mesures vont
impacter directement le budget 2023 de
la sécurité sociale et bien ça méritait
une rectification néanmoins c'est vrai
que on a beaucoup parlé du 47 qui est
devenu un petit peu le New 49-3 cela ne
se dégaine pas mais il faut bien le
redire l'article 47 ans et de droit
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'article qui
s'applique à la discussion en matière de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et c'est vrai que alors que
l'objet social n'apparaît pas forcément
au premier abord c'est à dire que
normalement c'est très serrés qui vont
avec le 47 ans
le débat a commencé à l'Assemblée en
commission des affaires sociales depuis
le début de la semaine qui se termine ce
soir ensuite 6 février jusqu'au 17
février ce sera l'hémicycle avec début
mars au Sénat et puis le 26 mars c'est
absolument sûr c'est la fin du parcours
législatif c'est la seule certitude
qu'on a en réalité le délai qui figure
dans la Constitution c'est ce délai de
50 jours le délai de 20 jours laissé à
l'Assemblée nationale et le délai de 15
jours laissé au Sénat plus le délai de
15 jours pour la navette entre les deux
sont en réalité des délais sur lesquels
vous pouvez obtenir une certaine
flexibilité de quelques jours quelques
heures mais ça signifie néanmoins que au
départ pourquoi est-ce qu'on a fait ce
47 ans et parce qu'il est aligné tout
simplement sur les discussions
budgétaires on a besoin de le faire
avant la fin du mois de décembre pour
pouvoir tout simplement voter un budget
de la Sécurité sociale qui permette
d'actionner les leviers de la dépense en
janvier comme pour tout budget là on a
moins cette urgence dans la tête parce
que c'est un budget rectificatif donc
déjà on s'était même posé la question
tiens est-ce que les délais vont
s'appliquer le Conseil constitutionnel a
tranchée
donc un petit peu hors sol et c'est pour
ça que l'opposition crie notamment au
déni démocratie en disant le fait de
choisir ce véhicule là il a une utilité
c'est d'aller beaucoup plus vite et une
autre utilité c'est que comme c'est un
texte financier et bien vous pouvez
actionner un 49-3 à l'issue du vote
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi et
ça j'aimerais vous entendre là-dessus
c'est qu'il peut ne pas y avoir de votes
à l'issue du débat dans dans l'hémicycle
comment comment on peut le justifier et
qu'est-ce que quel scénario ça
correspond à quel à quel scénario
l'absence de vote a priori on a 20 jours
pour l'Assemblée nationale 15 jours pour
le Sénat s'il a semblé national ne va
pas enfin ne vote pas au bout de ces 20
jours n'a pas donné son avis définitif
sur le texte dans son intégralité on
peut passer directement au scénario il
faut savoir sous la 5ème république ça
ne nous disait jamais arrivé une un
petit précédent pour une à disposition
ou en fait on avait un petit peu retardé
le calendrier on l'a fait aussi pour un
budget rectificatif financier donc oui
il y a une marge de négociation de
quelques jours qui pourraient permettre
qu'on sollicite un vote mais oui la
constitution ou la possibilité de
directement passer à la de ces assemblée
en quelque sorte comme un vote sanction
en disant ben vous n'avez pas respecté
votre timing donc on passe directement à
l'autre assemblée en tout cas pour
l'instant à l'Assemblée c'est que le
vendredi 17 à minuit vote ou pas mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez difficile de
figurer qu'est-ce qui va se passer
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un ministre qui
va dire allez je vous reprends les
textes je vais le donner à vos collègues
sénateurs c'est c'est une possibilité
c'est même peut-être ce vers quoi en
temps et effectivement ce serait inédit
les députés ne pourraient pas donner
leur avis ça ce serait le cas de figure
où il y a énormément d'obstruction et
que les débats sont lisent voire
tournent au pugilat et qu'on arrive à
aborder quelques articles c'est ça qui
intéresse à cette stratégie là la gauche
de la nuque ou pas forcément la Nupe
elle a intérêt à je dirais à tenir le
avait de l'Assemblée comme elle tient le
pavé dehors en réalité c'est peut-être
une faute de sa part c'est à dire que si
la nuque voulait vraiment mettre le
gouvernement en difficulté elle aurait
plutôt intérêt à justement ne pas faire
d'obstruction et à pousser le
gouvernement et la pousser l'exécutif et
toute la majorité a joué carte sur table
et à faire un vote parce que comme on
disait tout à l'heure et ben en fait
est-ce qu'on est sûr que l'intégralité
de la majorité va suivre est-ce qu'on
est sûr que la droite avec lequel avec
laquelle le gouvernement a un deal
est-ce que la droite va suivre jusqu'au
bout et ça c'est vraiment le point le
plus délicat
il y a probablement une erreur
stratégique de la part de la nuque de
bordéliser comme disent certains ou en
tout cas de ralentir les débats parce
que ça veut dire qu'il y a des tas de
débats qui ne vont pas avoir lieu
justement il y en a un qui est
exactement sur cette ligne c'est
François Ruffin il veut un vote au moins
un vote sur l'article 7 écouter le
on veut que le débat ait lieu sur le
point clé qui est l'article 7 et
l'article 7 c'est de la rallongement de
deux ans et on veut pas que le
gouvernement utilise le faible temps de
parole pour ne pas pouvoir discuter du
coeur de la réforme qui est de la
Contre-Réforme qui est cet article 7 sur
le report de deux ans voilà donc il y a
une vraie stratégique à gauche voilà la
responsabilité aussi des oppositions et
du Parlement d'arriver à se parler mais
qui la Nupe a justement un petit peu
changé de stratégie puisque au début
elle annonçait des dizaines de milliers
d'amendements et là elle a revu un peu à
la marge parce qu'elle en a déposé 4000
en commission ce qui est beaucoup mais
ce qui est quand même été filtré et
c'est pas tant elle qui a changé de
stratégie c'est que la Commission
elle-même a dit quand même ils en ont
déposer
de filtrage par la commission qu'on
espère être repris en discussion parce
qu'il y a toute cette question de
l'objet aussi et justement la nuque ne
veut pas forcément de votre finale
puisqu'elle veut continuer à dénoncer un
déni de démocratie un passage en force
donc ils ont trouvé une solution un peu
médiane c'est dire nous ce qu'on
aimerait c'est au moins d'aller sur
l'article prête là je les gale et là ils
peuvent avoir effectivement de par des
interrogations dans la majorité ils
peuvent gagner ils peuvent avoir une
victoire politique donc c'est pour ça
voilà chacun veut faire sortir du bois
l'adversaire il va falloir se compter à
un moment c'est pour ça que l'article 7
sur le recul à 64 ans et fondamental
vous pensez vous que le gouvernement a
plutôt intérêt à éviter au maximum le
vote c'est les scénarios idéal c'est la
fable du Lion et du renard le lion dans
la Constitution c'est le 49-3 un coup de
patte et s'il y a pas de révolte des
animaux de la jungle avec la motion de
censure et ben le Roi Lion il fait
passer son son texte là c'est le renard
le 47 ans c'est rusé vous voulez faire
obstruction très bien bah ça ira sans
votre Sénat ah bah tiens ça piège aussi
la droite parce que à l'Assemblée la
droite elle est comme ça on sait pas
trop qui va voter au Sénat chaque année
il vote 65 ans comme réforme des
retraites ils ont toujours été sur une
ligne dure s'il récupère le texte vierge
de tout vote qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire
les amis sénateurs de droite après il y
aura une commission mixte paritaire et
si tout ça se termine sans vote et bien
Emmanuel Macron pourra par ordonnance
appliquer sa réforme
en ayant expliqué aux Français que
heureusement qu'il y a un exécutif qui
s'occupe des problèmes et qui fait
avancer les réformes parce que le
Parlement c'est vraiment pas possible à
l'inverse évidemment les oppositions ont
vu le piège ils vont essayer de dire
c'est pire qu'un 49-3 c'est une sorte de
49 3 déguisé humiliant pour le Parlement
et bien sûr humiliant pour la rue en
espérant que l'adoption s'envote le
passage aux ordonnances va remettre des
gens en colère dans la rue à ce jeu là
on sait pas trop aujourd'hui qui sera le
vainqueur dans l'opinion ce qui est
évident c'est et c'est la cinquième
république qui le veut c'est que
l'exécutif à l'avantage de la maîtrise
des outils juridiques sauf que il y a le
Conseil constitutionnel et les
institutions peuvent être
contrebalancées par le bas la démocratie
dans la rue qui bloque parfois le pays
rappelez-vous la susmulation du CPE une
loi votée mais pas promulguée suspendue
par Chirac voté par l'Assemblée on
l'avait dit de susmulguer donc le peuple
avait vaincu les institutions et puis au
dessus des institutions il y a le
Conseil constitutionnel qui pourrait
après un 47 un dire attendez non non à
votre votre ruse compte tenu du contenu
de l'aspect cavalier non finalement on
casse certains articles ça serait là une
défaite juridique majeure pour
l'exécutif ça c'est possible ça craindre
qui est à craindre pour deux raisons
d'abord le délai sur lequel le Conseil
conditionnel n'a jamais vraiment eu à se
prononcer dans un cas où il y aurait eu
alors il y a un principe constitutionnel
qui est intéressant c'est celui de
clarté et de sincérité du débat
parlementaire donc les outils auront-il
été usé à bon escient là on aura une
réponse et surtout deuxième point
l'objet c'est un piège qui se referme
sur le gouvernement en quelque sorte
doit être une autre fable de La Fontaine
mais justement le Conseil
constitutionnel nous dit un projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificatif ne doit venir que
corriger les chiffres du budget de la
Sécurité sociale donc l'index senior le
Conseil d'État a déjà dit ça c'est très
borderline l'égalité salariale
homme-femme la condition des femmes
l'employabilité des seniors la
pénibilité toutes ces questions là ne
rentre pas fait justement on va en
parler ça nous amène au fond du texte
parce qu'il y a peut-être un autre texte
juridiquement c'est plus sûr alors
justement on va essayer d'entrer dans
dans les dans le détail du texte et
surtout sur le grain à moudre sur quoi
ça peut bouger on a bien compris que
c'est les républicains qui détiennent
les clés de cette réforme regardez un
tout petit peu les mystique pour bien
vous figurer les choses la majorité
Renaissance horizon et modem aujourd'hui
c'est 250 députés il manque donc 39 voix
pour atteindre la majorité absolue et
donc c'est évidemment à droite que le
gouvernement compte les trouver où en
est-on ce soir elles aiment un Gabin
avec Clément Perrot on menait l'enquête
auprès des députés de droite
[Musique]
prendre l'âge légal c'est clair net et
précis et le gouvernement c'est
désormais à quoi s’entretenir sur le
terrain dans sa circonscription des
Vosges Stéphane Viry chef de fil de son
groupe sur les retraites résume le
dilemme de la droite si on est pour
le RN va nous taper dessus à bras
raccourci on est la majorité on est
macroniste si on est contre ce qui pense
que la droite doit être responsable doit
savoir faire avancer le pays ils vont
nous dire vraiment vous êtes contre tout
vous servez à rien et pour ajouter à la
cacophonie les patrons des groupes LR à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat ne sont pas tout
à fait alignés est-ce que vous allez
voter cette réforme oui nous l'avons si
on ne fait rien du tout les retraites
des Français sont menacés certainement
pas donné un blanc sain alors même que
le débat n'a pas commencé dans
l'hémicycle pour faire adopter sa
réforme le gouvernement a impérativement
besoin de la droite sans elle l'ombre du
49-3 pourrait à nouveau planer sur les
débats
Christophe Barbier qu'est-ce qui se
passe à droite à l'Assemblée je précise
tout de même les 65 ans c'était le
programme de Valérie Pécresse il y a une
forme de cohérence à accepter cette
réforme et on a l'impression ce soir que
à droite ça va être à la voie près pour
obtenir cette majorité je pense qu'il se
joue un match politique et un match
sociologique le match politique c'est un
peu le match retour de la récente
élection à la présidente de LR ou
Aurélien Pradier a été battue par eriki
comme Bruno retaillod et donc Aurélien
Pradier dit je ne voterai pas parce que
je suis l'elgo je suis le social il veut
exister comme premier opposant dans son
parti c'est aussi le match retour de la
primaire de la présidentielle ou cioti a
été battu par Pécresse donc il veut lui
montrer qu'il l'aboutit à une réforme
puisqu'il la soutient plutôt mais en
ayant obtenu des gages et notamment des
gages sociaux mais derrière cela et
c'est plus profond je pense et plus
cornélien pour les élus de droite il y a
un problème sociologique c'est que la
plupart des députés LR aujourd'hui sont
dans des circonscriptions assez
populaires c'est plus la droite élue par
des retraités de centre-ville aisés
c'est une droite élu dans des quartiers
dans des zones rurales semi-urbaines ou
ça fait mal 64 ans donc leur électorat
peut leur dire la prochaine fois on
votera RN comme on l'a fait d'ailleurs
dans les circonscriptions alentours
c'est pas la même chose au Sénat vous
n'êtes pas élu de la même manière et il
y a pas la même culture de la réforme
Ouido d'ailleurs les députés le savent
bien ils n'ont pas du tout envie de
repartir sur le terrain en campagne en
cas de dissolution non et on va dire les
choses assez clairement ces derniers
jours quand ils sont rentrés en
circonscription ils se sont globalement
fait engueuler c'est à dire que j'en
discutait hier avec un député de droite
qui disait il y en a pas un il a fait
une réunion publique il y en a pas un
qui m'a demandé qui m'a dit vous avez
fait vous avez eu un programme avec 65
ans tenez bon allez-y jusqu'au bout non
il m'a dit j'ai demandé à la salle il y
avait 80 personnes il y en a cinq qu'on
levait la main en disant est-ce qu'il
faut voter et il y en a cinq qu'on dit
oui donc en fait ils sont effectivement
dans des bassins notamment qui ont
beaucoup voté Marine Le Pen et donc ils
sont aussi confrontés à ce jeu sur le
terrain et si ils savent que s'ils
reviennent imaginer ils votent la
réforme des retraites c'est un cas au
total ça se termine par une dissolution
euh donc ils sont obligés de retourner
euh devant les électeurs les électeurs
et leur disent quoi ok vous avez voté la
réforme des retraites en fait on va pas
du tout voter pour vous donc en fait ils
sont vraiment dans une situation assez
difficile c'est qu'il y a c'est quelle
raison ils auraient réellement de suivre
est-ce qu'on est un petit peu dans la
politique question est-ce qu'on en parle
en coulisse dans les déjeuner politique
est-ce que cette possibilité de la
dissolution du 49-3 d'une crise
politique c'est des choses qui sont
évoquées ouvertement oui bah clairement
de toute façon ils disent au Républicain
vous savez comment ça va se finir si
jamais vous votez pas les menaces d'une
dissolution mais c'est vrai qu'en plus
qui complexifie la tâche pour le
gouvernement c'est que là le deal avec
les républicains il va falloir qu'il
soit scellés c'est-à-dire limite
recevoir les promesses de vote des 62
députés pour être sûr que ça puisse leur
faire la majorité absolue voire
compenser quelques défections dans leur
rang donc là c'est vraiment un
engagement des républicains de d'appuyer
sur le bouton et cette pression dans les
circonscriptions pour ne pas voter cette
réforme me Marine Le Pen a très bien
compris parce qu'elle a dit vendredi
dernier je cite les électeurs LR doivent
interpeller leurs députés pour leur
expliquer qu'il n'est pas possible de
soutenir cette réforme d'une brutalité
inouïe c'est très compliqué d'être élève
en fait aujourd'hui bien sûr le lion le
renard et le vautour vous voyez celui
qui vient dévorer votre cadavre quand
vous êtes éliminé c'est pour ça que pour
les rosiers à 49-3 ça serait confortable
le gouvernement passe en force ils ont
pas à voter mais une motion de censure
elle est fille PSPC RN il la voteront
pas non plus au nom de la stabilité
celle de février 2020 alors qu'il y
avait une majorité absolue pour le parti
présidentiel est passé par 49-3 Édouard
Philippe avait eu recours aux 49-3 parce
qu'il était pas sûr de sa majorité quand
même incroyable de se dire que dans les
coulisses dans les états majors
finalement le 49-3 est peut-être la
moins pire des solutions
pardon je coupe mais ça arrange
notamment Marine Le Pen qui se dit ceux
qui ont voté contre la réforme des
retraites il se mobiliseront
en cas de motion de censure et donc ils
feront tomber le gouvernement et donc
elle elle pousse le bouchon encore plus
loin en disant j'ai même intérêt à faire
en sorte de fragiliser tout le monde
pour à la fin essayer de récupérer les
billes
de l'extérieur passé en force sans vote
par le 49-3 sur une réforme aussi
importante qui je touche à tous les
Français vous pensez que ça peut être
compris ça dans l'opinion non on le voit
bien avec les manifestations elles ne
sont pas simplement à Paris elles sont
en province et la pression effectivement
que vous évoquiez des députés elle est
énorme en ce moment
avec leur avenir politique en jeu en
quelque sorte donc ça sera de toute
façon très mal compris mais on a
l'impression que à chaque fois qu'on
cite le mot retraite ça se passe
toujours mal enfin je parle sur votre
contrôle c'est j'allais dire depuis
qu'on est adolescent nous on entend
retraite retraite et à chaque fois ça
passe pas donc on se dit quelle est la
solution parce qu'il y en a aucune la
dissolution n'est pas une peut-être que
le 49-3 en est une mais ça passera
toujours si ça passe on pense Christophe
c'est vrai quand on regarde l'opinion
pour l'instant elle ne faiblit pas en
opposition à cette à cette réforme mais
quand on regarde même par sympathisant
là c'est pas si évident y compris pour
la majorité il y a pas un bloc
macroniste parmi les électeurs derrière
cette réforme dans l'opinion les gens ne
veulent pas travailler deux ans plus ce
qui était à quelques années de la
retraite qui se disent bah voilà
l'horizon s'éloigne les plus jeunes qui
se disent bon bah on me fait un horizon
lointain puis de toute façon comme moi
je serai à la retraite ça sera pire
derrière je serais même pas qu'est-ce
que je vais toucher ça ne peut pas être
populaire c'est très fort maintenant
dans les études d'opinion il y a un
chiffre qui peut rassurer un peu le
gouvernement c'est qu'une majorité pour
l'instant des Français disent bon elle
va passer quand même voilà comme si leur
mobilisation leur volonté pour certains
même réclamer le blocage comme seul
solution pour faire reculer le
gouvernement tout ça c'était un peu un
théâtre d'ombre ça va passer parce que
du côté du Parlement l'arithmétique et
pour le gouvernement ça va passer parce
que tous les pays voisins l'ont fait
donc on est dans l'Europe on peut pas
rester quand même le vilain petit canard
ou le ou le favori et on le fera payer
plus tard c'est à dire on est contre on
sait que ça va passer on vous le fera
payer plus tard dans des rendez-vous
électoraux dans la ligne de ce que dit
Christophe Barbier elle ne passe pas
parce que il y a la souffrance au
travail pardon mais ça va être encore le
chroniqueur judiciaire qui parle allez
faire un tour dans les tribunaux dans
les prud'hommes bon les gens se
plaignent de la façon dont ils sont
traités mépris harcèlement tout ce que
vous voulez en fin de carrière donc on
est en train de leur dire il faut
travailler plus mais il faut travailler
dans des conditions épouvantables où il
y a le génisme où vous êtes donc à
partir d'un certain âge ni sur la touche
donc voilà il y a quelque chose là qui
est totalement contradictoire donc
peut-être régler un problème avant d'en
régler un autre peut-être faut-il régler
des conditions de travail avant de
régler le problème de ça et on a
l'impression que c'est un peu l'erreur
d'interprétation de base et c'est en
fait le macronisme est fondé sur le
travail sur la valeur travail c'est un
peu l'alpha et l'oméga pour eux et c'est
vrai qu'à mon avis ils n'ont pas vu que
pour certaines personnes ça pouvait être
des douleurs physiques ça pouvait être
des douleurs psychologiques et puis
aussi qu'il y avait tout un tas de
personnes notamment depuis le covid qui
se détache un peu du travail en disant
finalement moi je préfère aussi
équilibrer avec ma vie privée il y a eu
effectivement l'erreur de croire que
demander de travailler deux ans de plus
au français bah ça allait on en parlera
d'ailleurs dans le débat de demain le
changement du rapport au travail des
Français Anne-Charlotte du gouvernement
finalement c'est à dire qu'il y a eu une
focalisation sur l'âge de départ et il y
a eu une focalisation sur un véhicule
législatif dont on a déjà parlé qui est
très spécifique du LFSR mais justement
tout ça prouve une espèce d'hyper
spécialisation de ce débat qui méritait
d'être bien plus général et qui aurait
pu être accepté différemment pris par un
autre bord les Français sont assez
favorables au régime par répartition
sont très friands de notre principe
constitutionnel de solidarité qui fonde
le régime de la sécurité sociale et le
régime des retraites donc prenez le
problème de ce bord-là en parlant du
travail en parlant des générations
futures qui est un qui est un domaine
sur lequel on peut mobiliser ça aurait
été différent et je crois que justement
le fait de cristalliser le débat en 20
jours dans un projet de loi spécifique
en disant voilà on est obligé d'avancer
uniquement sur cette disposition là
c'est braquer le débat j'aurais mis
Baudot puis ensuite je voudrais que vous
nous disiez un mot sur quoi ça peut
bouger quand même en fait j'allais vous
dire du gouvernement c'est peut-être la
clause de revoyure qui est esquissée qui
est demandé par le modèle clause de
revoyure en gros pour expliquer
brièvement c'est l'idée de dire en fait
c'est peut-être pas 64 en fait c'est
peut-être 63 mais en 2027 et donc de
créer un rendez-vous présidentiel un
rendez-vous présidentiel ce qui pose
d'ailleurs d'autres questions d'un point
de vue institutionnel c'est-à-dire que
2027 va devenir un référendum pour ou
contre un projet sur les retraites qui
est quand même un peu un peu particulier
avec certains candidats qui pourraient
dire moi je m'arrête m'arrêter à 60 le
gouvernement c'est clairement une porte
de sortie qui est possible sur les
carrières longues 44 ans de cotisations
est-ce que ça c'est négociable est-ce
qu'il y a du grain à mou de là en tout
cas les députés de droite Aurélien
Pradier en tête en fait un casus Belly
pour voter ou non la réforme il dit si
le gouvernement ne bouge votre acontre
donc est-ce que le gouvernement
s'imagine qu'il va y avoir un vote et
devra les convaincre pour l'instant le
gouvernement plutôt à dire qu'on ne
bougera pas là-dessus il a pas l'air
prêt à bouger sur très cher aussi parce
que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher et fait
le risque que certains points au
gouvernement c'est d'avoir un peu la
double peine c'est-à-dire d'avoir fait
un peu le bazar dans le pays et puis en
plus d'avoir une réforme à la fin qui
rapporte beaucoup moins ce qui était
prévu Christophe Barbier vous connaissez
bien la droite depuis de nombreuses
années
vous sentez les choses comment il y a
quand même 60 députés LR Aurélien
Pradier on a compris qu'il était
vraiment très contre cette réforme mais
il emmène avec lui qu'une trentaine il
en reste une trentaine ou pas à votre
avis pour voter parce que dans ce dans
cette navette parlementaire le poids du
Sénat va être important sénateurs ils
sont muets pour l'instant on sait que ce
sont des gens qui travaillent sur le
fond qui arrivent avec beaucoup de
sérénité on n'aura pas d'obstruction on
n'aura pas et je pense qu'à partir du
moment où la droite sénatoriale ce sera
exprimée ça va être compliqué pour la
droite de l'assemblée de continuer des
jeux un peu politiciens cette sagesse là
risque de de s'imposer mais il manque
clairement
peut être compris même si ça n'arrive
pas tout de suite dans ce débat là en
disant attendez ça c'est dire des bas
budgétaires on va on va parler après
pénibilité par exemple oui mais ça je
pense que politiquement c'est compliqué
à porter vous pouvez pas dire vous
inquiétez pas le package global va être
formidable mais dans un premier temps ça
va être un peu dur je vous fais un
parallèle avec le début du quinquennat
2017 Emmanuel Macron avait dit on va
supprimer les 7 mais on va aussi
supprimer la taxe d'habitation il y a
tout de suite supprimer l'ISF il a mis 5
ans à supprimer la taxe d'habitation et
le ressenti dans la dans la population
c'est Macron président des risques c'est
quand même amusant de vous demander un
petit pronostic ça va passer à
l'Assemblée ou pas moi je pense ça
passera sans vote ça ira aussi
on n'est pas allé au bout des articles
en commission le fameux article c'est
que n'a pas été même examiné et le texte
va arriver tel que dans sa version
gouvernementale bien sûr ça c'est le
principe des textes financiers alors moi
je dirais oui peut-être et pourquoi pas
49-3 un peu sauce majoritaire en disant
justement mais nous sollicitons 49-3
pour qu'il y ait un vote donc ça peut
même aller dans le sens de la majorité
au niveau lexical les pronostic moi j'ai
envie de croire à l'intelligence du
Parlement et au débat donc sur l'article
7 pas en général mais en tout cas on
sera là vendredi 17 à minuit pour voir
comment ça se passe voilà évidemment
l'ensemble des débats sur les retraites
à l'assommaie nationale seront diffusés
en direct sur la chaîne parlementaire
donc soyez au rendez-vous sur cette
réforme qui concerne tous les Français
17 février anniversaire de la mort de
Molière pour faire du théâtre merci et
je rappelle que vous êtes un homme de
théâtre Christophe Barbier merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu sur le
plateau LCP vous restez avec moi
Dominique verdaghian dans une dizaine de
minutes nous affranchis ce soir Marco
poli va revenir sur la visite du
président du parlement ukrainien
l'assemblée l'Ukraine qui réclame à la
France des avions de combat Isabelle
Lasserre nous dira si c'est la prochaine
étape ou pas et puis la France qui
encaisse aussi une nouvelle hausse de
l'électricité la faute à la gare et bien
non la faute à l'Europe nous dira
Richard Werly a tout à l'heure les amis
faites entrer magistrat Dominique
verdaillant vous les aimez les juges
vous les avez même confessé magistrature
le divan reparé en poche trop seul face
à la misère du monde sont-ils mieux
accompagnés aujourd'hui on voit cela
juste après l'invitation tiboine
si l'on vous invite Dominique verdaillon
c'est que l'on ne verra jamais les yeux
de la justice mais qu'on connaît bien
les vôtres
de votre regard bleu et de votre voix
calme vous avez accompagné pendant des
années des millions de Français dans le
prétoire on s'est parlé on ne sait pas
entendu compagnon de JT avec vous nous
avons vécu tous les grands procès car
Paul Touvier a toujours fait un choix à
la justice des hommes il a préféré la
justice divine de fournirer à du trou de
la mort du petit Grégory à celle Dylan
Halimi des dossiers financiers comme la
Ferel à l'horreur des attentats
Dominique verdaillan vous avez fait
votre métier de raconter le pire de la
meilleure des manières chroniqueur
judiciaire pendant 30 ans pour France 2
vous avez tiré de votre expérience des
tribunaux la matière de plusieurs livres
où vous faites revivre l'univers si
particulier des salles d'audience chez
la théralisation c'est ce décor homme de
ces grandes salles d'assises toutes ces
personnes les magistrats les avocats
l'accusaient les victimes les
journalistes les jurés et puis c'est le
revers de la médaille c'est-à-dire que
tout ça c'est quand même la noirceur de
notre société parce que c'est c'est des
drames il pleure on crie on hurle dans
une salle d'assise dans ce déluge
d'émotions il en est pourtant qui sont
tues celle des juges quelle pensée
cache-t-il sous leur robe qu'elles états
d'âmes accompagnent leurs décisions dans
les magistrats sur le divan qui vient de
reparaître en poche vous leur donnez la
parole il se nomme Marc trevidicch
Laurent vicienyvski François Molin ou
Renault vandrinbeck et lorsqu'il brise
l'armure c'est d'abord pour dire la
charge mentale de leur fonction
l'opinion publique n'a pas conscience de
la masse de travail des magistrats mais
également de la masse d'angoisse tout ce
que l'on prend dans l'estomac on ramène
tout à la maison c'est faux de dire le
contraire des juges qui s'expriment
alors qu'ils sont en général tenus au
silence un silence difficile à tenir
confestile alors qu'ils sont souvent
attaqués
c'est toujours le même ressort pour
déstabiliser et discréditer l'action de
la justice ont la politique le magistrat
ne peut pas répondre ce sont des
positions où le silence s'impose avec
beaucoup de douleurs
montrez une justice à visage humain
Dominique verdaillan télé aussi le but
de votre dernier émission justice en
France qu'est-ce qu'il en porte entre le
droit et l'émotion dans ce genre de
dossier on y assiste à des audiences une
nouveauté rendue possible par une loi
votée en 2021 et qui permet
l'enregistrement et la diffusion
d'affaires définitivement jugée vous
pouvez vous asseoir alors Dominique
verdaillan une question pour finir cette
dimension humaine trop humaines de la
justice est sa force ou sa faiblesse
réponse
les deux c'est sa force parce que
il s'est rendu par des hommes
et c'est ce qui en fait ce côté
aléatoire ce côté défaillant
donc voilà c'est à la fois une force et
une faiblesse c'est-à-dire qu'on s'entre
bien compte en ce moment que
c'est la justice qui est défaillante
c'est l'institution judiciaire
les hommes aujourd'hui
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent on a parlé de
souffrance au travail tout à l'heure la
souffrance au travail chez les
magistrats c'est une notion très récente
c'est pour les défendre aussi d'une
certaine façon vous avez voulu les
confesser les défends non parce que ils
ont pas besoin de moi quand on voit
toute cette souffrance
il somatise ils ramènent la boule au
ventre les dossiers chez eux on imagine
pas vraiment ce qu'ils vivent oui et
d'ailleurs moi-même j'imaginais pas ce
qu'il vivait même si c'est venu de mes
propres souffrances entre guillemets en
étant chroniqueur judiciaire tout à
l'heure on assiste à des drames à des
pleurs vous me dites vous-même ça laisse
des traces on sort pas indemne d'un
procès bon
et et je me suis dit quand je vais leur
demander de me dire quels sont leurs
ressentis ils vont jamais me répondre
bon et puis comment vous avez réussi à
les convaincre les vanner une Bègue les
trévidiques
d'abord j'ai peut-être été le premier à
poser la question parce qu'effectivement
la notion de souffrance au travail
commence à être évoqué par les syndicats
avec des des livres blancs et que pour
une fois quelqu'un s'intéressait à eux
non pas pour les mettre en cause mais
pas pour les allonger sur un divan et
pour leur dire expliquez-moi qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui vous fait mal et et ce
que je dis au début de ce livre c'est à
dire que beaucoup ont accepté de me
parler beaucoup plus que je ne le
pensais sont près d'une centaine et
certains je ne pouvais plus les arrêter
c'est-à-dire que je remarquais qu'ils
avaient un petit post-it sur sur leur
bureau parce qu'ils avaient marqué
toutes les affaires
leur par scène de crime leur première
autopsie au fond leur première
confrontation à la mort c'est ça la plus
difficile le magistrat vient d'une
classe sociale plutôt élevée bon il fait
des études il va à l'école nationale de
la magistrature à Bordeaux il apprend le
judiciaire le juridique dans tout ça
peut-être pas assez l'aspect
psychologique on a vu ça avec l'affaire
Outreau avec Fabrice Burgaud et puis bah
voilà quand il sort de l'école nationale
de la meistrature il est juge
d'instruction il est jugent des enfants
il est juste des affaires familiales et
il est confronté à la douleur de l'autre
il faut savoir la gérer et donc
effectivement c'est quelquefois un
premier cadavre c'est quelquefois un
premier enfant qui va falloir retirer à
ses parents pour le placer dans dans une
le plus dur c'est les juges des enfants
qui qui raccrochent et qui restent pas
souvent Jean-Yves Coquillat c'est le
premier qui vous a dit oui ancien
procureur de la République dans la ferme
notamment Jean-Claude roman un vrai
semblable à faire de cet homme qui va
qui va mentir toute sa vie à sa famille
en lui faisant croire qu'il était
médecin à l'OMS et qui et qui préfèrera
tuer les siens plutôt que de sortir du
mensonge ça ça entre vie un magistrat
quand on quand on suit ce dossier là oui
des affaires comme celles de de
Jean-Claude roman elle a marqué tous
magistrats comme les magistrats que j'ai
rencontrés qui ont suivi l'affaire
fournirait ont été marquées par le
personnage par sa perversité
le magistrat qui a instruit le dossier
Jean-Claude roman donc ce faux médecins
de l'OMS me raconte que lorsqu'il fait
une reconstitution la maison où a été
tuée les deux enfants et la femme rien
n'a bougé et il y a justement dans la
cuisine un post-it qui est écrit par la
fille que Jean-Claude Romand a tué
donc voilà il y a une certaine émotion
qui se passe à ce moment là et et
Jean-Claude roman regarde le juge et lui
dit vous pensez pas quand même qu'elle
aurait pu soigner son écriture par de la
fille qu'il a assassiné et le juge me
dit j'ai entendu un grand bout à ce
moment-là c'est pas du tout Jean-Claude
roman qui s'effondre c'est le gendarme
qui est derrière parce que voilà c'est
hallucinant d'entendre une telle
confession on évoque des déluches
confrontés à quelque chose
d'inimaginable alors certains sont quand
même un peu plus blindés que d'autres
non très vite et Van Beck vous diriez
pas cela parce que ça pose la question
du rapport aux médias aussi certains
sont dans la lumière c'est vraiment la
minorité parce que vous décrivez bien le
profil type c'est la discrétion plutôt
mais ces juges là qui savent jouer aussi
de l'opinion ils ont un avantage par
rapport aux autres
oui alors certains ont cherché la
lumière aussi pour se protéger et pour
protéger leur dossiers après évidemment
vous avez des affaires où vous êtes plus
protégé et vous êtes plus protégé quand
vous êtes confronté à des affaires
politiques au financières même si
évidemment la pression sera totalement
différente
à gérer des crimes de sang des crimes de
de céréales killer et puis l'expérience
fait que oui on se blinde mais voilà
après on monte dans la hiérarchie et ça
devient autre chose il y a un fossé
abyssal dites-vous entre le temps
médiatique et le temps de judiciaire ce
sont deux univers totalement
asymétriques écrivez vous aujourd'hui le
tribunal médiatique il juge il jugent
souvent des affaires à l'inverse du juge
comment il le vivent les magistrats ça
très mal alors après la question c'est
de savoir s'ils sont influencés ou pas
évidemment quand on leur pose la
question ils disent non parce que on est
dans dans notre bulle mais
pas évident que quand vous avez devant
vous quelqu'un de médiatique quand vous
êtes en train de juger une affaire
médiatique vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
être impressionné alors bon c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est tout à l'heure
dans une démarche de dire on va pouvoir
filmer certains procèdes donc les
caméras vont pressoires ça va changer
les choses est-ce que ça va réconcilier
les Français avec leur magistrats
réconcilier je ne sais pas en tout cas
leur aider à comprendre comment ça
marche ou comment ça ne marche pas ils
sont quand même 65% j'ai regardé les
dernières enquêtes à considérer que la
justice est trop laxiste encore
aujourd'hui
presque à plus de 70% de gens qui sont
mécontents de leur justice alors
expliquons l'heure montrons l'heure
pourquoi ça ne fonctionne pas pourquoi
leur dossier demande autant de temps
montre en leur le le travail des
magistrats et c'est vrai que les quatre
émissions qui ont été diffusées jusqu'à
présent on s'aperçoit que dans une
audience vous avez 15 à faire les unes
derrière les autres avec des magistrats
qui doivent régler des décisions à
prendre des décisions assez importantes
dans un dans un minimum de temps alors
que l'affaire remonte quelquefois à deux
ans trois ans ou quelques fois plus on
parle parfois de la jalousie de certains
magistrats vis-à-vis des avocats parce
que parfois pas tous gagne leur vie on a
l'impression voilà certains magistrats
peuvent considérer que il y a une forme
de voilà de lumière peut-être qu'il
désire de garde des sceaux aujourd'hui
n'est pas magistrat c'est un avocat dont
la mais il a eu des mots très durs sur
sur les juges lorsqu'il était dé aux
acides il est aussi quand même le
Premier ministre en exercice à être
renvoyé par des magistrats devant la
Cour de Justice de la République pour
prise et illégale d'intérêt dans
l'affaire des écoutes téléphoniques
malgré les moyens supplémentaires
annoncés récemment il y a un divorce
consommé à votre avis entre les jugés et
leurs ministres il y a eu un divorce dès
le départ
déclaré que c'était une déclaration de
guerre le fait qu'on nomme
Eric Dupond-Moretti comme garde des
sceaux
c'est vrai que le Garde des Sceaux a
peut-être eu des mots maladroit pour
l'avoir suivi c'est quelqu'un qui met
ses tripes au milieu du prétoire donc il
met ses tripes au milieu de son bureau
de de l'Assemblée nationale
moi je serais tenté de dire aujourd'hui
on sait qui est le Garde des Sceaux au
moins au moins et il a mis la justice au
cœur du débat
il a lancé avec le président Macron des
États-Unis héros il y a un plan de
réforme qui l'a présenté début janvier
et vous avez peut-être remarqué que les
deux syndicats ont dit ah il y a des
choses intéressantes regardons donc on
est dans une période où peut-être les
rapports vont légèrement s'améliorer le
lien n'est pas complètement rompu
d'après vous les magistrats sur le divan
c'est à dire aux éditions c'est un
édition poche lithos voilà et puis je
vous l'ai signaler aussi que justice en
France votre programme surface de sera
diffusé prochainement sur LCP Dominique
verdaillant c'est l'heure d'accueillir
nos affranchis pour leur partie prix on
les accueille tout de suite Isabelle
Lasserre correspondant diplomatique du
Figaro Richard Wery correspondant France
Europe du quotidien suisse Le Temps
qu'est-ce que j'allais dire Blic
désormais bonsoir à tous les deux on
commence comme chaque soir avec Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco bonsoir
Myriam oui ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire d'une visite symbolique et
très politique près d'un an après le
début de l'invasion russe en Ukraine la
visite de rousselane Stéphane chouk le
président de la Rada le Parlement
ukrainien alors il a vu du beau monde
Emmanuel Macron Elisabeth borne le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher mais
aussi il y a El Brown privé il était
d'ailleurs ce matin avec la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale au programme
une visite dans un centre pour réfugier
Ukrainiens la France en a accueilli plus
de 100 000 depuis le début de la guerre
écoutez il y a LeBron TV
on voit des familles qui s'intègrent qui
ont le désir de pouvoir ici s'occuper
travailler avoir un rôle social être
ensemble aussi et puis ne pas être et ça
elles l'ont fortement exprimé ne pas
être déplacé à nouveau elles ont
retrouvé ici dans ce centre d'accueil
un collectif qui manifestement leur est
cher le président du parlement ukrainien
qui était particulièrement mise à
l'honneur hier pour la séance de
questions au Gouvernement très applaudis
par tout les groupes politiques qui ont
rappelé leur soutien à l'Ukraine c'était
la séquence standing ovation
[Applaudissements]
et ce président de la Rada et bien il a
remercié la France pour son engagement
auprès des Ukrainiens pour son aide
militaire notamment il a aussi demandé
aux députés français et bien de
reconnaître la Russie comme un état
terroriste évidemment il avait un
message politique cette visite elle
intervient en plein débat sur la
livraison d'armes lourdes à l'Ukraine la
semaine dernière les États-Unis les
Allemands ou encore les Anglais ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient livrer des chars
à l'armée ukrainienne alors qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait le président ukrainien et
bien il a réclamé les chars français les
chars Leclerc mais pas que
nous voulons voir parmi les Léopards les
Abrahams les challengers
l'éclairs français qui nous renforcerons
au sol mais également les mirages et les
rafales qui ensemble avec d'autres
avions de nos alliés protégeront le ciel
ukrainien
donner nous les avions
les ailes de notre victoire
Elisabeth borne lui a répondu la France
est prête à étudier les demandes
supplémentaires en termes d'armement
c'est ce qu'elle a dit de quoi inquiéter
certains groupes à l'assemblée qui
craignent une escalade avec la Russie
jusqu'où ira la France dans son soutien
à Kiev c'est la question posée par le
rassemblement national par les
républicains par la France insoumise
aussi ou les communistes et d'ailleurs
certains n'ont pas hésité à réclamer
devant roostland Stefan chouk une
solution diplomatique c'est-à-dire
négocier avec Poutine nous formons le
vœu qu'une solution diplomatique soit
trouvée au plus vite afin de garantir le
retour à la paix avec la volonté de ne
pas devenir cobelligérant et de ne pas
contribuer à une dangereuse escalade
guerrières par la livraison d'arme
lourdes offensives je vous demande
solennellement si le président peut
faire entendre au monde qu'un espoir
demeure en organisant avec l'ensemble
des parties une grande conférence pour
la paix
voilà et face à la gravité des enjeux
bien plusieurs présidents de groupes
parlementaires ont réclamé un débat sur
le rôle de la France dans cette guerre
merci Marco pommier transition toute
trouvée vous voulez avez suivi ces
visites diplomatiques Isabelle de très
très près vous avez rencontrésor de la
Rada puis aussi le ministre de la
Défense monsieur Reznikov il veulent des
avions de combat ils veulent norafal
c'est ça oui parce que ils en ont ils en
ont besoin en fait comme les comme les
chars lourds les Ukrainiens ont besoin
d'avions de chasse pour
affronter l'offensive annoncer des
forces russes au printemps et pour
tenter de reprendre l'avantage militaire
alors que leur armée pour l'instant
piétine dans le dans le Dombas c'est
parce que si ils savent les Ukrainiens
que le temps joue contre si jamais
Vladimir Poutine envoie comme il le dit
comme il le promet un million d'hommes
supplémentaires sur le terrain ça va
être très très compliqué de résister
pour les Ukrainiens il y a donc un
sentiment d'urgence et c'est pour ça que
les responsabilités Ukrainiens font la
tournée des capitales de tous leurs
alliés pour obtenir davantage d'armement
et la France est une cible toute trouvée
puisque avec son armée qui est censée
être la meilleure d'Europe elle a des
armes et elle peut en fournir Emmanuel
Macron lui-même de la pas exclu
puisqu'il a dit au début rien n'est
interdit par principe ça c'était
officiellement et en fait il a aussi
rajouté à condition que ça ne provoque
pas d'escalade supplémentaire et donc
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
proposition française sur la table et
les autres pays européens alors et bien
ça dépend desquels les Pays-Bas pour
envoyer des F-16 ils ont affirmé qu'il
n'y avait pas de tabou en la matière la
Pologne et la Slovaquie et réfléchissent
en revanche Joe Biden a dit non
carrément non idem pour le chanceler
allemand pour qui la question ne se pose
même pas au lave Scholtz redoute un
risque d'escalade il redoute aussi que
Moscou face à ce nouveau palier provoque
une escalade supplémentaire en
s'enprenant à un pays de l'OTAN où en
menaçant à nouveau d'util réaliser son
Harmon nucléaire tactique or les
Occidentaux ne veulent surtout pas d'une
chose rentrer en guerre avec la Russie
elle-même débat Myriam avec les missiles
à longue portée que se passerait-il
pense-t-on à l'ouest si c'est missile
était utilisé comme les avions de chasse
en territoire russe alors justement les
rouges
en théorie vous savez les depuis le
début de la guerre les lignes rouges
elles évoluent beaucoup pour l'instant
la question ne s'est pas posée parce que
les Ukrainiens ont fait extrêmement
attention de respecter les limites qui
leur avaient été donnés par les
Occidentaux et quand ils ont attaqué des
bases militaires en Russie c'était avec
des drones de leur confections ils
savent que l'issue de la victoire d'une
éventuelle victoire en Ukraine dépend
des armements occidentaux ils n'ont
aucun intérêt à trahir la période
occidentale une fois qu'on a dit ça on
peut quand même observer que depuis un
an l'engagement
occidental a glissé on a commencé à
livrer des chars aux Ukrainiens et
aujourd'hui on livre des chars lourds et
on s'interroge sur l'opportunité d'aller
jusqu'au avions de chasse alors ce
changement de portage ils expliquent par
l'attitude de Vladimir Poutine qui ne
veut pas négocier et qui n'a absolument
pas reculé sur ces buts de guerre et qui
dit être en guerre contre que l'OTAN est
en guerre contre les évidemment il
aurait été plus facile de l'arrêter
quand il a attaqué la Géorgie en 2008
quand il a annexé la Crimée en 2014 ou
même au tout début de la guerre quand il
a essayé de s'en passer sans parler de
Kiev mais les Occidentaux à l'époque ont
préféré fermer les yeux il paye sans
doute aujourd'hui le prix de leur
passivité aujourd'hui n'ont plus le
choix que de s'engager davantage auprès
des Ukrainiens parce qu'ils ont compris
enfin que les conséquences d'une défaite
de l'Ukraine serait trop plutôt pour la
sécurité de l'Europe pour la démocratie
et pour le droit international merci
beaucoup c'était très clair merci
Isabelle Richard on enchaîne avec vous
vouliez nous parler d'une info qui est
passée un peu sous les radars parce
qu'elle est un peu écrasée par la
réforme des retraites c'est les tarifs
de l'électricité ça va encore augmenter
au 1er février donc aujourd'hui en
moyenne de 15% et vous nous dites ce
soir c'est pas forcément les
conséquences du conflit en Ukraine c'est
aussi pour des raisons européennes alors
en tout cas c'est les deux et à propos
de l'augmentation vous savez qu'en
France il y a quand même le bouclier
tarifaire qui a grosso modo protégé les
usagers français mais effectivement il y
a une question j'en suis sûr que tout le
monde s'est posé ici et noter les
spectateurs c'est pourquoi nos factures
d'électricité ont explosé à ce point il
y a pas si longtemps j'étais dans une
boulangerie ils avaient affiché leurs
factures c'était près de 20 000 euros
alors il y a bien sûr les raisons qu'on
connaît c'est à dire la coupure du gaz
russe etc etc mais il y a aussi de
vraies dysfonctionnements du marché
européen de l'électricité qui remonte à
1996 depuis on essaye de faire converger
l'approvisionnement électrique
officiellement pour faire baisser les
prix alors moi j'attendais depuis des
mois qu'un rapport se penche sur les
dysfonctionnements de ce marché européen
électricité et rien ne venait le credo
de Bruxelles ça restait on n'est plus on
est beaucoup mieux loti ensemble
souvenez on a acheté les vaccins
ensemble ça allait beaucoup mieux etc
etc et bien voilà que la Cour des
comptes de l'Union Européenne basée à
Luxembourg elle s'est réveillée et dans
un rapport qui a été publié hier elle
détaille toutes les entraves que ce
marché européen de l'électricité qui
était supposée les enlever il y a toutes
les entraves qu'il a rajouté elle montre
combien la concurrence n'a pas été
efficace elle montre combien il n'y a
pas une absence de convergence trop de
réglementation trop d'opportunités
surtout pour les revendeurs d'énergie
qui sont venus sur ce marché ils étaient
supposés investir eux aussi pour
produire de l'électricité ils n'ont pas
du tout fait ça ils ont juste fonctionné
comme des grossistes ils ont acheté de
l'électricité ils ont profité et ils
l'ont revendu alors le problème c'est
que on sait que les tarifs ont augmenté
à cause de l'Ukraine mais il faut bien
le dire ils ont augmenté aussi parce que
l'Europe n'a pas su gérer son marché de
l'électricité en clair les États membres
ont pris une sacrée décharge est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas renationaliser ce
bien commun de l'électricité non ce
qu'il faut faire c'est le ménage
l'électricité c'est un bien commun on
s'en aperçoit elle est indispensable
pour nous pour l'économie alors basta
les commerçants d'électricité qui ne
produisent rien c'est aux électriciens
européens de s'unir à eux de converger
d'investir ensemble et surtout de
s'interconnecter c'est à eux aussi
d'adopter un même prix qui ne doit pas
être indexé seulement sur le gaz comme
c'était jusque-là le cas dans beaucoup
de pays donc tout ne va pas si mal
attention dans l'Europe unie par exemple
en 2022 on a eu un pic d'énergie
renouvelable à plus de 20% du mix
énergétique c'est une réussite on va
dans la bonne direction celle d'une
économie décarbonée mais alt à la
spéculation le moment c'est fini d'en
finir avec ce bug il faut éviter les
courts-circuits bravo quelle chute en
voilà un parti pris merci quelque chose
me dit ça prendra encore un petit peu de
temps voilà la grande réforme de la
tarification de l'électricité en Europe
merci beaucoup merci
pour cette émission à demain même lieu
même heure
[Musique]